GILBERT STRANG: I'm coming
back to the number one
example, but not
the easiest example,
of a second order equation
with an oscillating
forcing term, cosine omega t.
We have to know the
answer to this problem.
And it's a little messy,
but the method is not messy.
The method is straightforward.
So let me begin by looking
for the rectangular form.
I call this the
rectangular form.
It separates the cosine
with its amplitude
and the sine with its amplitude
into two separate pieces.
So if I'm looking
for that solution,
and m and n are the numbers I
want to find, how do I proceed?
It's a case of undetermined
coefficients, M and N.
And the way to determine
them is substitute this
into the equation and match the
cosine term and find M and N.
And the way we find M and
N, we need two equations
for two quantities, M and N.
And imagine this
substituted in there.
I'll get some cosines.
So the cosines on one
side will match the cosine
on the other side.
And also from the derivative,
I'll get some sines
and they should match 0
because I have no sine omega
t on the right hand side.
So I have two equations,
matching the sines,
matching the cosines.
And I solve those.
Two equations, two unknowns.
And I just write
the answer down.
M involves a C
minus omega squared.
M is coming from the cosines.
And we get cosines from
that term and that term.
Divided by some number,
D, that I'll write down.
And N is just B omega
divided by that same D.
And now I'll write down D.
That's C minus A omega squared
squared plus B omega squared.
This is what comes out from
the two equations for M and N.
I just solve those equations.
This D here is the
two by two determinant
if we think about the linear
algebra behind two equations.
And that's what it is.
And so the answer now is
in terms of A, C, B, and D,
which is a mixture of all of A,
B, and C. That's the solution.
Only I always want to show you a
different form of the solution.
And in this case, a better form.
Because the most important
physical quantity
is the magnitude.
How large does y get?
What is the amplitude of this?
This is a sinusoid.
And we remember
that every sinusoid
can be written in a polar form.
Says that y of t is
some amplitude of G,
the gain, times a cosine
of omega t with a shift,
with a lag, with an angle alpha.
So I have two numbers now.
That's the gain.
And this is the
phase shift alpha.
And that's an attractive form
because it has only one term.
The two numbers, G and alpha,
get put into a single term
where we can see the
magnitude of the oscillation.
And what does that
come out to be?
I won't go through
all the steps.
I'll just write down
what G turns out to be.
G turns out to be--
it comes from there--
and it's 1 over the
square root of D. Well,
G is the square root of
M squared plus N squared.
The square root of M
squared plus N squared.
And if I put M
squared and N squared,
then I have D over D squared.
I get that answer.
That's the gain.
Let me write that
word, gain, again.
Because you got it there.
Here it is again.
And as always, the
tangent of alpha
is the N over the M, which
is just B omega over C
minus A omega squared.
I like that polar form.
And I feel I should
just do an example.
I didn't do any of the
algebra in this video.
But you know where
the algebra came from.
It came from
substituting the form
we expect for the solution.
And of course, that
form that we expect
is the form we get provided
omega, the driving frequency,
is different from omega N.
Well, no.
I guess we're all right even
if omega is omega N, because we
have a damping term.
So that's the answer.
So an example.
Why not an example?
y double prime plus y prime
plus 2y equals cosine of t.
That's a simple example.
I took omega to be 1, you see.
And there is omega.
And then A is 1, B is 1, C is 2.
We can evaluate everything.
In fact, I think
M and N are 1/2.
D, by the way, will be 1
squared plus 1 squared.
That's 2 square root.
Sorry.
D will be 2.
1 squared plus 1 squared.
So what do I know?
Do I know the rectangular form?
Yes.
Rectangular form is 1/2.
1/2 for both the
cosine and the sine.
1/2 of cosine t plus sine t.
That's the rectangular form.
Two simple things, but
I have to add them.
And in my mind, I
don't necessarily
see how the cosine
adds to the sine.
But the sinusoidal identity,
the polar form, gives it to me.
So what is it in polar form?
So G, the gain, is going to be
1 over the square root of 2.
At the highest point, the cosine
and the sine are the same.
They're both 1 over
the square root of 2.
I have two of them.
So I get 1 over the
square root of 2
cosine of t minus pi over 4
is the angle, the phase lag.
When I add the
cosine and the sine,
I get a sinusoid that's sitting
over pi over 4, 45 degrees.
So those are the two forms.
So in a nice example, we
certainly got a nice answer.
We certainly did.
Yes.
So that is the-- worked out,
more or less worked out,
in principle, worked
out-- is the solution
to what I think of as the most
important application when
the forcing term is a cosine.
So it gives oscillating motion.
It gives a phase shift.
And it gives these formulas.
The only thing I would
add is that I need
to comment on better notation.
So I have used in these
formulas A, B, and C.
But those have meaning as
mass, damping constant,
spring constant.
M, B, and K.
And it's combinations
of those that come in.
So let me just take this
moment to say better notation.
Or maybe I should say
engineering notation
instead of A, B, C, which are
mass, damping, spring constant.
Well, that's already
better to use
letters that have a meaning.
But the small but
very important point
is that two combinations
of A, B, C, M, B, K
are especially good.
One is the natural frequency
that we've seen already,
square root of C over A.
Square root of K over
M. So that gives us
one important
combination of A and C.
And the other one is
the damping ratio.
And it's called zeta.
And that damping ratio is B
over the square root of 4ac.
Ha!
You'll say, where
does that come from?
Or I can use these letters, B
over the square root of 4mk.
That damping ratio
is, so to speak,
it's the right
dimensionless quantity.
The dimensions of this
ratio are just numbers.
Those two quantities
have the same dimension.
And we can see that because
in the quadratic formula
comes-- you remember that
in a quadratic formula
comes the square root
of b squared minus 4ac?
Now if you see a formula that
has b squared minus 4ac in it,
you know that these must
have the same units.
Otherwise, subtraction
would be a crime.
So they have the same
ratio and the same units
and therefore the
ratio is dimensionless.
Let me write that word.
Dimensionless.
So conclusion.
I could rewrite the answer in
terms of these quantities omega
n and zeta.
I won't do that here.
That can wait for another time.
But just to say since we've
found a solution to the most
important application
with cosine omega
t there, since we
found the solution,
appropriate to comment that we
could write the answer in terms
of omega n, the natural
frequency, and z, zeta,
the damping ratio.
Thank you.